hey it's Jessica would you sell out your
friends to make a quick buck are we
hardwired to be selfish I don't know
let's say the streets of bind out
you and another person have just been
caught after a recent crime spree the
detectives on the case have put you each
in the room for interrogation the
detectives give you two options you can
snitch on your partner giving them three
years in prison but you go scot free or
you can stay quiet and spend one year in
the slammer your partner in the other
interrogation room is given the same two
options with the same outcomes if you
both snitch on one another you both get
two years since you cooperated with the
cops ya are both still filthy of the
crime this leaves you with four possible
outcomes
if you both stay quiet everyone benefits
from spending the least amount of time
combined in prison but you trust your
partner to make the same selfless
decision we went to the street to see
how people will react but instead of
prison time we offered them cold hard
cash so what would you do
snitch or stay quiet my name is Jessica
what's yours Katherine hi Katherine
Susan hi Susan okay how do you guys know
each other from work cool do you guys
like each other yeah you guys are decent
people so you guys are brothers right
correct do you think Robbie's a good
person
okay do you think Stephanie ever here is
a good person how about we're gonna play
a game you guys ready yeah we're gonna
pretend you guys you guys did something
you guys stole something okay and you
guys are both being interrogated if one
of you snitches and the other one
doesn't one of you gets three dollars
but if you both snitch you both only get
one dollar but if no one snitch if you
go up get two dollars does that make
sense see you guys okay I need you guys
to stand back-to-back write down what
you're gonna do if you snitch on your
brother or if you don't one two three go
and three you guys going to show each
other one two three you guys are good
brothers good job we're not gonna rat on
each other good the people on the street
we're all being very nice so we decided
to raise the stakes see if that would
change anything how do you guys know
each other
stay there dude how long have you guys
been dating you're gonna take the money
and run
and then I counted three you show each
other one two three money even with
higher stakes most of the contestants
prefer to go with the prize that
benefits the group my usually
advantageous is usually ed we've known
each other a long time we went to school
together like you guys knew each other
three years three years okay okay so you
guys been friends for a while right so
you know say Oh BAM so far everyone
who's played knew each other beforehand
let's see what happens when we grab two
complete strangers Bobby hi Bobby
err moment Wow perfect and here's your
pen and then the count of three I want
you to write on the board whether you
would snitch on the random person you
just met
okay so in a count of three I want you
to show the camera one two three and now
show each other you guys would both yeah
I thought about it yes and I don't know
him he committed the crime I want to
protect my own life it's just not that
emotional yeah there you go so why were
people more likely to cooperate with
people that they knew I'm not a
psychologist but it could be because
humans are social beings we tend to
cooperate when we believe the payoff is
not worth the potential risk it's
possible that we view the risk is higher
when playing and someone we know because
there's a chance of it hurting our
relationship but what if the prize was a
hundred two thousand or six million
dollars how much money you were to take
the sellout your friends I wouldn't
fifty five